some people always like you know the
idea that someone should take care of
them but the problem is you're turning
over healthcare to the government the
people who run the post office the
healthcare legislation increases access
to care but it doesn't put in place the
kinds of policies that would reduce
costs and that is as important because
if you just increase access to care its
unsustainable and you'll have to ration
care and then the government will have
to ration care which makes me
uncomfortable and I hope it makes you
uncomfortable putting your trust in the
government is kind of pushing your luck
I think the biggest potential is in
reducing the cost of care so that we
don't have to restrict access as much
and I see us as able to reduce the cost
of care by reducing state regulations on
the way medical professionals are used
and the way that healthcare is provided
if we get out of hospitals and into
other kinds of provider services like
the retail clinics that you're seeing in
Walmart I think that is going to be a
way to reduce the cost of healthcare but
also to expand coverage
Healthcare is provided today the same
way it was provided 4050 years ago you
go in you see a doctor they talk to you
you leave but it's not necessarily the
most efficient way to provide a service
but the regulations make it so that
there's no other way to do it use of the
internet and email you know physicians
have have been really slow to adopt that
because there's no reimbursement code
for it if a patient sends you an email
message you don't get paid you need them
to show up and look at you and you need
to talk to them you know face to face
before you're going to get reimbursed
Kaiser Permanente in Hawaii put in an
email system for their patients and they
reduce office visits by 25% if you need
to check up for your car you would go to
a Jiffy Lube on a Saturday or a Sunday
and they are after work and they would
get you in and out in a little while if
you need a smog check you go in now
there's these smog check places you go
in you wait and you're done and we don't
see that in health care and you have to
ask why not and many people don't get
physicals a lot of the majority of the
population doesn't get a physical and so
if you could make it more accessible you
could
maybe do more to improve healthcare then
link the office visits with medical
professionals kind of like what FedEx
did to the post office look how good
that turned out
you know FedEx started out by taking the
stuff that the postal service wasn't
doing very well and soon the Postal
Service had to compete and really
reinvent themselves so that they could
do overnight delivery but the hospitals
have been much more effective than the
Postal Service in restricting
competition in their markets and making
it so that if you want to set up
something that's different or that has a
different structure that might be more
cost-effective you can't you know a lot
of people think that government
regulation protects consumers and so
they say well we need more regulations
instead of less but I've spent the last
decade looking at state licensing and I
can tell you it's not protecting you
once you say that doctor has to be
licensed then the medical professionals
get organized and they say well here's
what you have to have to have a license
because we want to restrict entry well
they don't say it that way but that's
the objective is to reduce competition
so that they can earn more most physical
therapists in the United States have a
bachelor's degree and so the idea that
we should convert to a system where they
all have a doctorate is just
tremendously constraining and expensive
people have this idea in their head that
more education is always better and it
kind of presumes that somehow because
you did go to this particular program or
the state did license you that that
means something just because you went to
school and you pass some test it doesn't
mean you're competent now or it
certainly may not mean you're competent
in 30 years state licensing does almost
nothing in terms of protecting you from
physicians who might be negligent or
engage in substandard care
really the only solution to bringing
down the cost of healthcare is to make
patients have to shop like no one knows
what things cost in health care in the
United States you don't know your doctor
doesn't know and if nobody knows what
things cost you just buy things
indiscriminately and that's why health
care is so expensive if you had a health
savings account you'd be looking for a
kind of Jiffy Lube place to do your
physical you know you wouldn't say oh I
need to go and see my doctor and spend
twenty minutes with him and you'd say
well where can I go to get a physical on
a Saturday where I don't have to pay
tons and then you might do it more
frequently and the cost of doing
physicals would fall dramatically if we
don't shop around if we don't if we're
not active participants in this market
we're gonna end up with a system that's
very stodgy and with less innovation and
more expensive than it needs to be
you